today we're dropping a massive bomb into
the Mariana Trench but we're not
stopping there we're also going to Nuke
a hurricane and a volcano what happens
when you drop one of the deadliest
weapons known to man into the world's
greatest natural wonders let's start our
nuclear experiment by dropping a nuke
into the Mariana Trench how would you
deliver a nuke to the bottom of the
Mariana
Trench what would this underwater
explosion be
like and what kind of Destruction would
it
cause this is what if and here's what
would happen if we nuked the Mariana
Trench welcome to the deepest darkest
depths of the ocean the Mariana Trench
is located in the Western Pacific Ocean
just 300 60 km away from the island of
Guam you'll be traveling down 11 km to
Challenger Deep the deepest point of the
trench here you could stack about 30
empire state buildings on top of each
other before hitting the surface you'd
be among the brave few to venture into
these high pressure pitch black and near
freezing Waters joining the company of
scientists a naval officer and even
filmmaker James Cameron but you'll be
carrying the most precious cargo of all
the biggest nuclear bomb ever
made okay wait before you worry about
what would happen if you exploded a bomb
at the bottom of the trench you'd want
to figure out how to get it there safely
if a bomb accidentally exploded near
near the surface it could be dangerous
for many people you could think of it as
a massive nuclear
tsunami waves hundreds of meters high
spreading out in all
directions this could create a hazardous
situation for the islands neighboring
the Mariana Trench like Guam Japan or
the
Philippines luckily these waves would
behave different differently than your
regular tsunami waves they would break
earlier that means they'd be smaller and
less catastrophic when they reached land
but still better to avoid this crisis
and get that bomb safely down into the
trench to do this you'd have to protect
it from extremely high pressures at the
bottom of the trench the pressure is so
high it would be like having 100 100
adult elephants on your head you'd want
to use a special pressure vessel to
transport the bomb just like operation
Wigwam in
1955 the United States detonated a bomb
at a depth of 600 M it was twice as
powerful as the bomb dropped on
Hiroshima the explosion generated a
massive bubble across the water and
deadly r radioactive contamination
spread across 13 Square
km but your bomb would be the largest
nuke ever created more like the SAR
bomba this nuclear weapon was over 3,000
times more powerful than little boy the
bomb dropped on
Nagasaki and you'd have to take it much
much deeper than the Wigwam
test at the moment moment of detonation
a bubble of hot steam would expand
rapidly in just a few seconds it would
cover an area of about 1
km on the surface you'd see a massive
bulge in the water but it wouldn't reach
Great
Heights that's because you would
detonate the bomb so deep that the water
pressure above would cause the bubble to
collapse but within a few seconds that
bubble would shrink then start to expand
outward again this expansion and
contraction would continue for three or
four
Cycles this would leave the water
turbulent hot and mixed with radioactive
debris at least no neighboring coastal
cities would have to worry about being
wiped out by a
tsunami but you certainly wouldn't see
the effects ending
there The increased temperatures from
the explosion could create intense
hurricanes and the turbulent Waters and
radioactive material would have adverse
effects on marine life there would be
Mass casualties from the explosion and
deep sea fish could be blinded by the
bright flash of light over time you
could see unexpected or surprising
effects on the ecosystem near the
detonation site there are corals as big
as cars after the 23 detonations at the
US nuclear testing site on bikini at tol
not to mention an abundance of aquatic
animal
life but you could see mutations of
marine life after a while now that's
what would happen if we nuked the
Mariana Trench but let's move our
nuclear weapons from the sea all the way
to the sky
let's nuke a
[Music]
hurricane every year about a half a
dozen hurricanes reach the United States
with effects ranging from heavy winds
and some flooding to the decimation of
communities destroying homes and Taking
Lives
instead of bracing for impact with our
sandbags and survival kits what if
hurricanes never hit land at all what if
we could stop these hurricanes by nuking
them how would we do
it could this cause a nuclear
apocalypse or would a bomb even stop a
hurricane this is what if and here's
what would happen if we nuked a
hurricane
but first what exactly are
hurricanes well they're massive storms
that form over warm ocean water near the
equator hurricanes are tropical storms
the water they form over needs to be
above 26° for them to work this warm
water creates humid air which then gets
thrust upwards by tropical winds to
create storm clouds lighter winds
outside the clouds steer them and help
them
grow this cycle keeps happening until
the storm has winds of at least 119
kmph at that point it's called a
hurricane they're usually about 160 km
in diameter and can be nearly as large
as the state of
Texas oh yeah and did we mention that
these things can last for days you
definitely don't want this coming to
your home so let's nuke
it believe it or not the idea of nuking
hurricanes isn't new it's been proposed
for decades dating back to the
1950s the idea works like this a
submarine would travel underwater to
below the eye of the storm once there
the sub would launch the nuclear bomb
creating an explosion intended to blast
out all the hot air and bring in cold
air which is denser the cold air would
slow down the wind and stop the
hurricane okay we have our nuke and are
ready to launch
it there it
goes and well nothing happened the
hurricane is still there that can't be
good the reason nothing would happen is
because of the amount of energy a
hurricane produces according to the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration the heat released from a
hurricane is equal to a 10 Megaton
nuclear bomb exploding every 20 minutes
in 1990 all of humanity used 20% less
energy than a single Hurricane produces
so the average bombs of today would
hardly make a dent on a hurricane not
only that the hurricane would carry all
that radiation plutonium and other
civilization destroying materials from
the air down to the
land as if a regular hurricane wasn't
bad enough we'd now have a radioactive
one
as it moved across America it would
destroy cities with its wind and water
while also dumping radiation on
them okay let's try this
again this time we'll use an even bigger
bomb and we mean really big to have
enough energy and force to stop a
hurricane you'd need more than 100
atomic bombs but to keep it simple let's
pack all that power into one Giant Bomb
if we released such a massive bomb it
would surely stop the most epic of
hurricanes but once the dust settles
you'd quickly realize that you destroyed
most of the Earth in the process so
whichever way you attempted nuking a
hurricane is not a good idea and
unfortunately the number of hurricanes
continues to increase researchers say
that the warming of the oceans due to
climate change is a reason why
hurricanes are getting strong ER and
more frequent and no we can't nuke that
problem either so nuking a hurricane is
a terrible idea okay for our last
hypothetical experiment let's try
putting these nukes to good use by
detonating them inside of a
volcano what happens
next
volcanoes the ultimate natural force of
Destruction they're
unforgiving
uncompromising and
Unstoppable about 1,500 volcanoes around
the world are considered to be active
with more than 10% of them in the United
States is there any way we could stop
them before the destruction
begins could we literally Fight Fire
with
Fire what if we nuked an active
volcano would it solve the
problem or May make it way
worse this is what if and here's what
would happen if we nuked an active
volcano volcanoes are as cool as they
are
terrifying they are an incredible force
of nature capable of destroying our
lives on their path of
Destruction but could we give them a
taste of their own
medicine how could we nuke such a fiery
Inferno Well we'd need to bring out the
big
guns the nuclear bomb dropped on
Hiroshima Japan during World War II was
the equivalent of over 130 million kg of
TNT that had plenty of impact could we
use something like it to blow a volcano
to
Smither first we'd have to figure out
the
target while it's difficult to predict
when a volcano will erupt there are some
warning
signs watch for things like tiny
earthquakes releases of steam and other
gases from the volcano's mouth and
bulging from the sides sounds like my
last
date that being said whether the volcano
will erupt is still a massive educated
guess so let's say that our scientists
locked on to an active volcano that's
ready to blow it would be a miracle if
they could coordinate with the military
fast enough to try and stop it ideally
we'd be able to predict it a few days
before before the volcano was about to
explode this would provide more than
enough time for people to pack up their
belongings and evacuate without causing
the kinds of highway traffic jams we see
during hurricanes tsunamis and other
disasters with everyone out of Harm's
Way geologists volcanologists and
weapons experts would determine any weak
spots on a volcano's sides that could be
hit
effectively next a highly trained crew
of Pilots would fly over the volcano Dro
their payload and get the heck out of
Dodge if things worked perfectly as in
if they used the exact right amount of
explosives and hit the perfect spot in
exactly the right way the top of the
volcano would crumble into itself
keeping the magma mostly underground
there might still be some seepage around
the base of the volcano but it wouldn't
be anything like how the eruption would
have played out naturally but if we're
being being honest it would be like
trying to put out fire with
gasoline geologists warn that trying to
bomb a volcano might actually make
things worse a lot worse the explosion
of the bomb mixed with the buildup of
pressure inside a volcano could amplify
the eruption the force would release
even more Ash and lava spreading it even
further than it would have gone with the
volcano's own power and that's if we
managed to hit the target
if the nuke missed its Target there's
still a nuclear bomb being dropped in an
area where people live or at least near
enough that they would feel the effects
of the
radiation if you had to pick one which
would you choose death by lava or
nuclear
destruction we can't bomb our way out of
this problem the same way we can't stop
magma from building up under
volcanoes here at what if we've tried
throw throwing trash and pouring liquid
nitrogen into
volcanoes long story short it doesn't
work don't mess with
volcanoes as cool as it sounds on paper
nuking a volcano just won't work while
manmade Firepower can be impressive
nature isn't quaking in its boots at
what we can do but since we're messing
around with volcanoes well why don't we
use them for some good like dumping all
of our trash into
one but that sounds like a story for
another what
if